now the surging gas prices which are
actually as it turns out much worse in
other countries they're bad here they're
worse elsewhere the latest numbers show
that drivers in britain are paying
nearly twice as much as we are here it
cost more than 120 to fill up the
average family car over there and our
charlie daggett has been talking to
people in london who are telling him the
cost of driving there is changing their
lives
if you think your pain at the pump hurts
sparrow thought for london's infamous
black cab drivers it's ridiculous the
price
is ridiculous i'm retiring next year
because of this rate because of the fuel
fuel prices that are forcing extra
overtime to make up losses tell me
another way i can make money or go and
do it and far worse than prices in the
united states nearly nine dollars a
gallon and rising gas prices here in the
uk have been skyrocketing increasing by
the day and there is no end in sight
it's got to the point where people are
simply deciding they can't afford to
drive anymore
so what exactly is to blame and why
should america care americans should
care because one this is a global
situation
prices globally are increasing economist
sam timms says the uk is a bellwether
for what's coming to the u.s one of the
big reasons here is that the uk and the
eu as well
have decided to stop importing russian
russian fuel and that's going to push
prices up however the uk only directly
imports around six percent of its oil
from russia that's even less than the us
imports
but the war in ukraine and the
international sanctions against russia
have caused a spike
in global crude oil markets plummeting
supply post-pandemic demand more
commuters and vacationers on the road
and expensive oil becomes expensive gas
if there is any silver lining the crisis
may serve as a time to rethink not only
dependence on russian fuel
but on carbon fuels in general do we
want to be incentivizing people to be
spending on fuel on kind of carbon
emissions or do we want to be pushing
them towards greener uh greener
renewable energy for cbs mornings
charlie dagetta london